C'était impec.
Karen ?
C'est ton frère !
Alan !
Qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
Et bien, nous devions nous voir
Pour préparer notre week-end et St De Palmas.
Tiens, tiens, Steven !
Qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
Rien, rien, on discutait...
Ah oui ? Et vous discutiez de quoi ?
Des pâtes !
Des pâtes ?
Y a pas grand chose à dire sur les pâtes, si ?
Je suis très curieux de savoir ce que vous disiez à ce sujet tiens !
Merde il a raison, c'est nul comme thème les pâtes.
Mais si je ne trouve rien à dire de marrant sur ce thème,
Il va comprendre que nous n'étions pas du tout en train de discuter !
Ça fait plaisir de vous voir monsieur Podcast.
Ça fait longtemps.
D'ailleurs j'ai croisé vos fils, Alan et Steven,
Toujours en train de se tirer la bourre.
Ils sont en tout cas en très bonne santé.
Ce qui n'est malheureusement pas... votre cas.
Alors ?
Vous disiez quoi ?
Je lui disais, notamment, que...
Attends, qu'est ce que je disais déjà ?
La fourchette...
Pour qu'y ait qu'une fourchette...
Il me disait que... ce qui est marrant avec les pâtes...
En tant que proche incontesté de votre famille...
Je me dois de vous dire la vérité.
A la vue de vos examens, j'ai le regret de vous annoncer que...
Vous êtes décédé !
Monsieur Podcast, vous êtes...
Décédé.
La nouvelle doit être dur à encaisser.
Excusez moi, je...
C'est tout à fait normal de prendre un peu de temps pour...
Digérer cette nouvelle.
Monsieur Podcast...
Pendant que j'y pense...
Avant que la mort ne vous rattrape...
Aviez vous...
Choisi lequel de vos fils...
Allait reprendre l'entreprise familiale ?
Monsieur Podcast ?
Steven ? Alan ?
Ah ! Je sais !
Dîtes rien une fois...
Pour Steven.
Dîtes rien deux fois...
Pour Alan.
Dîtes rien trois fois si...
Décédé !
Décédé ! Oui !
Pardon, je...
Depuis tout à l'heure je suis en train de vous mettre la pression.
Alors que vous êtes dans l'incapacité de répondre.
Car vous êtes décédé.
J'espère que vous ne m'en tiendrez pas rigueur.
Ah oui ! Vous êtes décédé, pardon !
Rohlala ! Mais ça veut pas rentrer !
C'est fou ! Vous savez quoi ? Je vais me le noter !
Parce que je sens que ça va durer je sais pas combien de temps.
Donc je vais noter ça... hein.
Je suis désolé hein.
C'est... ça me reprend à chaque fois.
Là, maintenant que c'est noté, je peux pas oubli....
Ah ! Mais je vous parle encore !
Décédé ! Décédé ! Décédé !
Je retiens pas...
Attendez...
Oh la boulette !
En fait vous êtes vivant !
Voilà ! J'ai... j'ai juste confondu les dossiers.
J'ai confondu avec monsieur...
Monsieur Podcoust !
Monsieur Podcast ?
Vous n'êtes pas mort !
Tout va bien ! J'ai...j'ai juste échangé les dossiers.
Vous êtes sûr ?
Oui ! Comme je vous l'ai dit, j'ai juste échangé les dossiers.
Donc vous m'avez fait venir pour rien ?
Ah la bourde !
Quand je pense que j'allais prévenir vos trois fils !
Je me serais bien retrouvé comme un con !
Mes trois fils !
Allo ?
Mes trois fils ?
Bah alors ?
Vous avez oublié tout ce que vous avez dit ?
Euh...
Je sais !
Faire cuire des pâtes al dente...
Et faire jouir une femme...
C'est pareil !
C'est un timing très minutieux.
Et à chaque fois, je me foire.
Bien joué Steven !
T'es le meilleur.
N'est ce pas Karen ?
Hein ?
Non, c'est parce que j'ai dû la faire jouir une fois, grand max.
Qu'est ce que tu viens de dire ?!
Merde ! Quel con !
Je suis pas sûr d'avoir tout écouté mais y a une chose que j'ai retenu.
Ce n'est pas du tout ce que tu crois Alan !
Vous avez fait des pâtes !
Hein ?
Oui !
Oui ! Voilà c'est ça ! On a fait des pâtes !
Mais on a pas fait de pâtes ?
Oui... euh oui !
Oui, on a fait des pâtes !
Cool !
Une quantité euh...
Elles sont où ? Je peux en avoir ?
Oui, vos trois fils.
Steven.
Alan.
Et Brandon ! Votre fils caché !
Bon sang ! J'oublie systématiquement que j'ai un fils caché !
Moi j'oublie souvent que... non j'ai honte de le dire !
Le cellier a l'odeur de caca qui est dans cette pièce.
Bon !   Bon bah voili voilou !
Sans rancune ?
Qui de Alan...
Ou de Steven...
Ou de...
Brandon
Hey ! Vous avez vraiment fait des pâtes ou pas ?
Reprendra l'entreprise familiale.
Vous le saurez prochainement dans Les Frères Podcast.
Et sûrement pas dans l'épisode suivant hein.
Mais bon, lâchez pas !